je pense que y compris pour les débats
que va lire le Conseil constitutionnel
peut-être peut-on définir très
rapidement ce qu'est la la laïcité et
comment on l'entend parce que sinon on
s'y perd madame la sénatrice il me
semble vousz cité ces trois choses
reconnues désormais depuis très
longtemps notre droit d'abord c'est un
principe de neutralité de la part de
l'état de la part de l'État et de ses
serviteurs d'abord de ses fonctionnaires
et des gens qui travaille en tant
qu'agent public ils n'ont pas à montrer
évidemment leur croyances religieuses
par en faire la promotion et ça vaut
aussi pour leur raisonnement politique
ou syndical mais en tout cas là pour la
cité une question évidemment religieuse
c'est le fait que l'État ne préfère
aucun culte ça veut pas dire d'ailleurs
qu'il ne peut pas non ça veut pas dire
qu'il ne ne peut pas les ici ou là les
aider il peut le faire dans le cadre de
la sécurité on subventionne par exemple
des caméras de vidéprotection pour les
cultes et puis aujourd'hui désormais
l'accession au handicap mais ça veut
dire qu'on ne subventionne pas et
d'ailleurs je constate que le Conseil
constitutionnel ne l'a jamais d'ailleurs
constitutionnalisé ce qui d'ailleurs
leur pose une question sur ce que entend
exactement la loi de la République comme
principe fondamental de la République et
troisièmement il y a une liberté de
culte et notamment d'expressions
religieus notamment dans le domaine
public on entend souvent qu'il faut
cacher ses appartenances religieuses
dans le sur le domaine public c'est
évidemment le contraire de la laïcité la
laïicité c'est la permission justement
d'exprimer puisque l'article 10
déclaration des droit de l'homme prévoit
que on peut on peut présenter ses
opinions même religieuses le même étant
montrant sans doute qu'elles sont par
nature dangereuses sans doute opinions
pour les révolutionnaires de 1789 donc
c'est la neutralité des agences c'est la
liberté de culte et donc évidemment de
ne pas croire en même temps de pouvoir
exprimer ses convictions religieuses y
compris sur le domaine public et c'est
évidemment la question de de son
subventionnement la laïcité bien sûr
qu'il faut la respecter ce qui ne serait
pas respectable en effet c'est une
pression sur les uns ou sur les autres
ou un agent qui voudrait montrer un
agent du service public bien évidemment
qui voudrait montrer son opinion
religieuse mais la laïcité c'est aussi
aussi des règles qui ont conduit à la
neutralité notamment des des lieux où
les enfants vont à l'école tout
simplement et donc le fait de pouvoir de
façon répéter à l'école publique vouloir
être dans l'opposition à notre principe
de laïcité qui à la fois l'expression
publique religieuse dans le domaine
publique mais aussi l'accept
l'acceptation de la neutralité des
agents de l'État et de certains lieux
qu'on qualifie de sanctuaire républicain
qui est l'école publique B il me semble
que ça doit être sanctionné voilà on ne
peut pas s'en prendre à quelqu'un qui
est dans la rue porte un vêtement
religieux s'il respecte les règles de la
République on ne peut pas en tant
qu'agent public revendiquer ou
contractuel revendiquer une opinion
religieuse et on ne peut pas euh
violenter les règles fondamentales de la
République et la laïcité et donc la
neutralité pour les agents comme pour
les euh les les les les enfants euh de
neutralité religieuse alors après moi je
suis très heureux madame la sénatrice
d'entendre que le Parti socialiste
revient à à la règle de 1905 il m'a pas
paru ces dernières années que c'était
tout à fait le cas que n'avez-vous
votter que n'avez-vous voté que que
avez-vous voté un centre de disposition
qu'on vous a présenté mais chacun le
sait chacun chacun le sait chacun le
voit il y a encore mais il y a encore
heureusement des laïques il y a encore
heureusement des laïques au Parti
socialiste mais pour pour il y en a
encore il y en a encore j'imagine je
l'espère mais en tout cas
majoritairement les alliance avec
Monsieur Mélenchon ne permett pas de
penser vous êtes désormais les
défenseurs absolus de la laïcité donc
voilà assumezvos assumez assumz assumz
les alliances politiques que vous avez
avec des gens qui manifestement donnent
des coups à cela voilà c'est c'est pas
grave on peut le dire non mais voilà
donc je pense qu'on peut le dire voilà
je pense qu'on peut le dire et vous le
savez non c'est pas une utile vousmême
vous faites Paragon de vertu simplement
vous n'êtes pas très
propre